hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about ketone body utilization in my
earlier video in the biochemistry
playlist I have already discussed about
ketone body production and its
metabolism but today's video would be
more focused on how ketone body is
utilized once produced let's imagine we
are undergoing starvation and in a
starve State our body do not get any
calorie input externally that means we
need energy right at that step and at
that particular starved situation even
if our body is not getting energy from
outside but our internal vital organs
cannot stop working for example our
brain cannot stop firing our heart
cannot stop pumping right so some
alternative format of fuel is required
to keep our body alive or keep our
internal organs active so in the starved
state the body would start to look for
alternatives first of all it would use
its own reserves first of all it would
use its glycogen Reserve which is
present in the muscles and in the liver
now once the glycogen reserve is over it
would start to use amino acids fatty
acids whatever it can get to make
glucose and utilize that now whenever
that is even finished it would start
break down the Faerie acids from the
adipose tissue it would start oxidizing
the fat and as a result huge amount of
acetyl co a would be produced now you
can see that our bodies try to encounter
the starve step by using several
alternate options right but at a point
of time when the body is going
undergoing prolonged starvation all the
reserves and all the stored resources
would be gone and that situation what
the what the body would do
in this situation body has its
alternative fuel a reserved will in a
car in this resolve will is known as
ketone bodies now just like any kind of
situation a kind of City there is a
factory which produce or manufactures a
product and that product is now utilized
in cities towns or villages right
similarly if we think about ketone
bodies as a product this product is
produced by liver in a certain situation
known as starvation or another disease
situation which I am NOT going to talk
about in this video and once produced in
the liver it is utilized in cardiac
muscles in brain and in kidney now the
question is that when as body starts
making ketone body and exactly how the
body or several internal organ of the
body utilize that ketone body it turns
out ketone body can easily go to the
brain and serve as an alternative fuel
and it can pass through the blood-brain
barrier barrier thereby recharging the
break brain in the state of prolonged
starvation imagine you don't have any
cash in your hand
but you need to pay your bills in that
situation you can do two things
one you can utilize your savings to pay
your bills and the second thing you
should stop saving at that moment when
you don't have any money right you
should rather focus on spending than
saving now the situation for our body is
the same in a starved state when we
don't have calorie free input our body
should focus on more catabolic processes
than an anabolic process question is at
a molecular level how does our body know
that we are undergoing an energy deficit
let's look at that and in that
perspective let's look at the ketone
body metabolism in a bit so our body
uses a currency which is
now ATP is the currency of the body
right now this energy currency would go
down during the stage of fasting and
since ATP is utilized the amount of a MP
would be increased so clearly there is a
dis balance in the a MP vs ATP ratio now
this change can be recognized by certain
sensors known as a MP dependent kinase
or AMPK mpk is also known as master
regulator of catabolism in a second we
would understand that NPK out of many
things first thing what it would do is
inhibit the mTOR complex mTOR is known
as the master regulator of catabolic
anabolism so it is very similar to a
process when you need to pay bills you
don't have money you stop saving so by
stopping mTOR mpk ensures all the
anabolic processes are paused for a
moment and now the body would focus more
on spending whatever it has to generate
energy now ampk would give rise to
activate PG c 1 alpha p GC 1 alpha
eventually activate PP AR 1 alpha now
this PP R alpha give rise to or help in
transcription of ketone body product
ketogenesis genes or the enzymes that is
required for ketogenesis PG p p AR alpha
help to transcribe that and as a result
the body would now start producing a lot
of ketone bodies and now body is now
more trained or more educated in terms
of production of the ketone bodies
now in normal state the brain can
utilize glucose glucose inside the brain
in the process of glycolysis get
converted into pyruvate and the pyruvate
enters the TCA cycle and thereby produce
energy now in the starve state what
happens is the ketone body level in the
blood is increasing so the ketone body
enters the brain with the help of mono
carboxylate transporters MC t1 and i'm
city two once it is crossing the
blood-brain barrier and it's in the
brain the brain can start utilizing or
start breaking down that ketone body to
make a intermediate that it can use to
produce energy one of the abundant
ketone body is beta-hydroxybutyrate
beta-hydroxybutyrate gets converted to
acetyl acetate by the help of the enzyme
beta hydroxy butyrate dehydrogenase now
acetoacetate get converted to acetyl-coa
by the help of beta key to s I weight
transference remember this beta key to
acyl transferase enzyme is only present
in extrahepatic tissues not present in
the liver now why it should be present
in the liver because if it is present in
the liver
it would break down ketone there right
so we don't need any mechanism which can
break down ketones
in the liver because liver is the
production half of ketone bodies and we
don't want the liver to break down get
on there so otherwise other part of the
body won't utilize the ketone body right
so be ready to aside weight transference
is not presenting liver but it's present
in other tissues like brain like heart
like kidney etcetera now from acetic
acid away Tyra's would convert it to
acetyl Kawai now this acetyl co a can be
channeled into the TCA cycle now brain
really doesn't care where does it get
the acetyl qwave from once it has the
acetyl co a it can chan
to TCA cycle to get energy right and
that is how even in the starve state the
brain don't stop functioning and it can
still get the energy that it needs same
situation is valid for the heart and the
kidneys were with the help of same
enzyme the ketone bodies are broken down
and the acetyl co a can be utilized in
the TCA cycle to produce energy and that
pretty much summarize how ketone bodies
are utilized in the extrahepatic tissues
during starvation and also we have
discussed that how body sends is that
there is an energy deficit and now it
has to start producing and utilizing
ketone bodies in several places I hope
you enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give a thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you